something you said in the last question
reminds me of the missed opportunities
scenario and I know when I was a little
girl there was a section in our
newspaper where I grew up about missed
opportunities I'll never forget this one
post was about a man that saw some woman
he described her and he said we shared a
moment and if that's you can you please
call me and I've never forgotten that
post and I mean this was pre Craigslist
you know I know all that exists now but
why are we so enthralled with the idea
of missed opportunity a missed
opportunity is a factor of idealism
because that opportunity is not fact
it's an opportunity it's a possibility
and on to that we can cast all of our
dreams and I think most of us have had
those moments you know the glance across
a room you're crossing a street you look
at somebody they look at you and you go
yeah and then you both walk about
anything should I just go stand on that
street corner forever and waits them to
come by again and some people do but I
think the thing about a missed
opportunity most at its core the reason
that it reaches us so deeply is it
offers that question what if and we can
see might that have been the perfection
that deep in our hearts we are all
striving for so do most romantic
comedies feature the missed opportunity
or the sort of even if it's just a
friend at a wedding that they see across
the table that they say hello to isn't
that sort of the core because the what
if yes the missed opportunity can be the
storyline of an entire film or the main
storyline of it for instance in Four
Weddings and a funeral the Hugh Grant
character definitely has a missed
opportunity through line and fortunately
he resolves it and he and Andie
MacDowell get together again but with
the three-part structure of a romantic
comedy that's the best sad part about
and the tense part about that second
section yeah you saw what it could be
and now it's gone because one of you had
to move or somebody got in the way or
someone else's you know in positions of
propriety are keeping you apart and so
that missed opportunity which is a
vessel if you will for idealism and
perfection really bothers us and we are
driven to pursue what might be a perfect
situation and now it's a romantic comedy
and they always stop when the people get
together right we do have to get into
the part about dissolution and
domesticity and all that stuff but we
get to keep that illusion of perfection
and that idealism
you